là c'est du coup c'est bon la caméra
c'est bon en fait je pense
qu'effectivement c'est finalement une
sorte de destin qui était un peu
prédestiné met effectivement en tout cas
il ya une volonté de vouloir casser un
salon de systèmes est en tout cas
essayer de donner des trajectoires de
sortie parce que casser c'est facile
mais en sortir et trouver des chemins un
peu viable ensuite sur le long terme
c'est déjà compliqué et franchement
j'aime m'y attelle et c'est pas voilà
c'est pas toujours aisé être radical
s'est pas forcément avoir une vision
politique des choses qu'on imagine tout
de suite vers la signification politique
que c'était un peu à voir mais je pense
tout simplement retourner à la racine
c'est vraiment le sens de ce terme
original donc à la racine des choses en
fait c'est une quête devrais je pense
que la société à laquelle on est elle
est radicale mais pas forcément pour une
fois dans sa mère sur la politique
[Musique]
le fait d'être conforme à quelque chose
n'est pas en soi le gênant ce qui est
plus gênant c'est l'embourgeoisement
mais la réalité de la concrétisation est
toujours extrêmement éloignée de ses
idéaux là c'est en cela qu'il ya un
conformiste d'arc a abandonné voilà
l'exemple typique je sais pas ce serait
quelqu'un de sciences po ou de n'importe
quelle école que j'ai rien contre eux
sciences po en particulier qui va parler
d' humanitaires pendant tout son master
qui va faire des voyages humanitaires
travaillent et dans les associations etc
pour forer des puits d'eau en ethiopie
il est très bien je dirais absolument
indispensable qu'il y en ait et puis
après bah finalement ils vont travailler
dans le consulting dans une grosse boîte
du cac 40 ou dans n'importe quel type
d'entreprise d'ailleurs donc un moment
donné l'un n'est pas forcément y'a rien
qui m'aura là dedans je veux dire mais
effectivement il ya quand même un moment
donné un vrai problème de vouloir sauver
le monde et deux ans après se retrouver
à pouvoir faire une carrière de
partenaires dans une grande boîte de
consulting dont les clients eux mêmes se
foutent complètement des combats de
jeunesse de la versa
[Musique]